♪ [music] ♪
In the last session,
we started our discussion on valuation
by talking about two ways you can approach
valuation. You can value just the equity
in a business or value the whole business.
And we talked about the inputs you need
to value a company. In this session,
I'd like to talk about two
of those inputs: cash flows and discount
rates. When you're doing a discounted cash
flow valuation of a company,
you obviously need to estimate cash flows,
but what are those cash flows?
There are three definitions of cash flows
you can get if you focused on
equity investors. The first,
and this is the oldest definition of cash
flow, is to look at what investors
actually get from the company.
And equity investors get only one cash
flow from the company and that is
dividends. So the oldest version of a
discounted cash flow model,
you discount dividends.
Increasingly over the last 20 years as
we saw in the section on dividends,
companies have been returning cash not in
the form of dividends but in the form
of buybacks. So an expanded version of
cash flow to equity investors looks
at dividends plus buybacks,
but you're still assuming that companies
pay out what they can afford to do to
their stockholders. In the discussion
of dividend policy, we also looked at
potential dividends where we estimate how
much a company can pay out in dividends
by looking at the cash flows leftover
after every conceivable need is met,
reinvestment needs and taxes,
and that cash flow is free cash flow to
equity. Three versions of cash flows
for equity investors: dividends,
dividends plus buybacks,
and free cash flow to equity.
That is, if you're valuing the equity
in a company. But what if you're
valuing the entire business?
The cash flow you then have to estimate
has to be a pre-debt cash flow,
a cash flow before debt payments,
but after taxes and
after reinvestment needs.
To estimate that cash flow,
we're going to start with the
operating income, not net income.
We're going to act like we pay
taxes on that operating income,
and we're going to subtract out
reinvestment needs. What we're left
with is a free cash flow but it's
a free cash flow to the firm.
Note that the difference between free cash
flow to the firm and free cash flow
to equity is free cash flow to the firm
is before debt payments,
free cash flow to equity is after debt
payments. So let's talk about estimating
these cash flows using the companies
we've been talking about through this
entire class. Let's start with
Deutsche Bank. I value
Deutsche Bank twice,
once in 2008 and once in 2013.
In 2008, I value Deutsche Bank
the way I used to value all banks then.
I valued based on dividends. Implicitly,
I was assuming that dividends reflected
the cash flows that Deutsche Bank
could afford to pay out in 2008,
and I did a dividend discount model.
By 2013, though, I was no longer
comfortable discounting dividends partly
because Deutsche's dividends were in flux
and partly because I'd lost faith in
managers and banks paying out what they
could afford to in dividends.
So I estimated the free cash flow
to equity. This is actually the
computation I laid out when we talked
about dividend policy would
estimate the free cash flow
to equity for a bank,
I suggested you start with the net income
and you subtract out the reinvestment in
regulatory capital that the bank has
to make. Based on that measure of
free cash flow, Deutsche's free cash flow
to equity in the next year is negative.
What does that mean?
Not only does it say that Deutsche
cannot afford to pay dividends,
it says that Deutsche will have to raise
equity over time to cover its requirements
and reinvestment in regulatory capital.
So free cash flow to equity for Deutsche
in 2013 reflects the fact that I no longer
trust the dividend payments to be what the
cash flows of the bank are. Now, let's
expand this discussion to Tata Motors.
To get the free cash flow
to equity for Tata Motors,
I followed the more conventional route.
I started with net income.
I subtracted out Net CapEx minus
Depreciation. I subtracted out the change
in working capital. And then I brought in
the cash flows from and to debt,
from debt in the form of new debt issues
and to debt in the form
of debt repayments. I got the free
cash flows to equity every year.
And you can see, the numbers shift over
time and the equity reinvestment rate
which measures how much I'm reinvesting
back of my net income also shifts
over time. So free cash flow to equity is
a cash flow left over after debt payments.
Let's look at free cash flow to the firm,
a pre-debt cash flow,
and let's use Disney to illustrate this
process. In the fiscal year ended
September of 2013, here's what
Disney's numbers looked like.
It had operating income of $10,032
million. Notice the subtle shift away
from net income. The effective tax rate
that Disney paid across its income is 31%.
Its CapEx for the year was $5.239 billion.
That includes acquisitions and its
depreciation was $2,192 million.
To get to the free cash flow to the firm,
here's what I'm going to do.
I'm going to start with my after-tax
operating income which is $6.92 billion.
From that, I'm going to subtract out my
net CapEx, the difference between
capital expenditures and depreciation,
and I'm also going to subtract out my
change in working capital because that
drains my cash flows as well.
My free cash flow to the firm for Disney
is $3.188 billion. Note that these are
cash flows before debt payments.
Equity investors will get only a small
slice of this, but it is an estimate of a
pre-debt cash flow. Incidentally,
using those numbers,
I can estimate my reinvestment rate
which will come in handy when we talk
about growth. The reinvestment rate is my
total net CapEx which is $3,732 million
divided by my after-tax operating income
of $6.92 billion. That gives me about 54%,
and that is what Disney reinvested
in the 2012-2013 financial year.
So free cash flow to equity is after debt
payments, free cash flow to the firm is
before debt payments.
Let's turn our attention
to discount rates. When you're doing a
discounted cash flow valuation,
are discount rates a critical
ingredient in your valuation?
Obviously. It is discounted cash flow
valuation. That said though,
I think we pay far too much attention to
discount rates and valuation and too
little attention to cash flows,
but much of what we've said in the context
of capital structure and investment
analysis about discount rates is going
to help us when we talk about discount
rates when it comes to valuation.
Again, remember, if you're
discounting cash flows to equity,
the discount rate you need is a cost of
equity. And for Deutsche Bank,
I estimated the cost of equity in 2008 and
2013 using exactly the same techniques
I used when I computed cost of equity
for investment analysis.
I started with the risk-free rate and
notice how much that shifted between 2008
and 2013. I used a beta that reflected a
bottom-up beta, and that changed as well,
and finally, an equity risk premium
that reflected the price of risk.
Put differently, everything in my inputs
changed between 2008 and 2013,
but my overall cost of equity for
Deutsche Bank decreased slightly
from 9.23% in 2008 to 8.8% in 2013.
Now, to compute the cost of equity
for Tata Motors, I did my analysis
entirely in repeat terms.
Why? Because I'm going to do my valuation
in repeat terms. I started with the
risk-free rate in Indian rupees, 6.57%.
I used the bottom-up beta for Tata Motors
based on automobile companies.
I multiplied that beta by an equity risk
premium that reflects where
Tata Motors operates, the 7.19%.
Bringing those numbers together,
my cost of equity for Tata Motors
is 13.5%, exactly the same cost of equity
I've been using for Tata Motors all the
way through this analysis.
Finally, let's turn to Disney.
Here, because I'm looking at a pre-debt
cash flow, a cash flow to the firm,
I need a cost of capital.
To get to a cost of capital,
I started with a cost of equity for
Disney. The risk-free rate, the beta,
and the risk premium that you see in that
computation are the numbers we've already
computed for Disney.
The risk-free rate is a U.S. dollar
risk-free rate. The beta is a
bottom-up beta reflecting
the five businesses that Disney was in in
2013. The equity risk premium reflects
where Disney does its business.
The 8.52% is my cost of equity.
To get to the cost of debt,
I start with Disney's actual rating.
I used a default spread,
netted out the marginal tax rate.
Remember that because the interest
saves you taxes at the margin,
you have to use the marginal tax rate,
and the cost of debt after taxes I get
is 2.4%. Looking at the weights for equity
and debt in market value terms,
I have 88.4% equity based on the market
value of equity of $121.9 billion.
And I have 11.6% debt ratio based on the
market value of debt which includes leases
of $15.96 billion, my cost of capital
for Disney is 7.81%.
Incidentally, if that number looks
familiar, it's a number that we used as a
hurdle rate for Disney in investment
analysis. It's also the number from which
we started our discussion on optimal
debt ratios for Disney in the Capital
Structure section. The one final point I
want to add when you talk about valuation
that we did not talk about in the context
of investment analysis and capital
structure is in valuation,
we forecast out cash flows for a company.
And as we forecast out cash flows for a
company, that characteristics of the
company might change. In the case of
Disney, for instance, when I value the
company, I would start at a 7.81%
cost of capital but I will let that cost
of capital change over time. Why?
Because I would expect the beta to change
as Disney becomes a more mature company.
I would expect the debt ratios to change
And as those two numbers change,
my cost of capital which starts at 7.81%
is going to end at 7.29%.
So in valuation, the cost of capital can
and should change over time
as your company changes over time.
So think about doing this for your
company. Start off by estimating cash
flows in the most recent year.
Don't get ambitious yet and try
to forecast cash flows. Look at
how much your company made and
how much it reinvested. Also,
if you've already got a cost of equity and
cost of capital you've estimated for your
company, get it ready because that's going
to be the starting point for discount
rates in your discounted cash
flow valuation.
♪ [music] ♪